[Música]
soy mamá de agustín de 11 años cuando me
enteré que estaba embarazada
me llene de felicidad y de esperanza
obviamente tuve los temores que tenemos
todas las madres primerizas
a los cinco meses me entero que ese bebé
sería un varón nada podía hacer
perdónate los botón importante
nada podría ser mejor para mí que ser
madre de un varón era mi sueño que mi
primer hijo sea varón
proyectaba a qué escuela iría
seguramente sería
seguramente sería músico como su papá
quizás pensaba que sería escritor
abogado planifique para él muchas
profesiones
pero al año y ocho meses de agustín yo
me separó de su papá desde ahí
comenzamos los dos solos
agustín comenzó jardín a los tres años
pero agustín no tenía control de
esfínteres o sea no podía dejar los
pañales hablaba con mucha dificultad no
tenía contacto visual
y no podía interactuar con sus
compañeros
agustín ante personas desconocidas se
escondía debajo de la mesa o se iba a la
habitación sino se escondía atrás mío
todo eso en jardín había entrado el
jardín que yo había elegido cuando él
estaba en mi vientre
paso salita de tres salita de cuatro
llegamos a preescolar y todo seguía
igual
agustín no lograba dejar los pañales
agustín no tenía contacto visual agustín
tenía muchas dificultades para hablar y
agustín se seguía escondiendo ante las
personas desconocidas
por recomendación del pediatra y del
colegio
buscamos ayuda ante distintos
especialistas fuimos a psicólogos
psicopedagogos neurólogos nadie nos
podía decir que era lo que agustín tenía
así pasaron de los 3 a los 7 años de
especialista en especialista de médico
en médico cuatro años recorriendo
distintos consultorios médicos
hasta que el pediatra me recomienda una
neuróloga y así fuimos
ella él observó
me hizo una serie de preguntas y me dijo
tu hijo va a ser como una plantita si
vos proyectaba que tu hijo terminaría la
secundaria te puedo decir que no lo va a
lograr
agustín continuaba con siete años sin
tener control de esfínteres con su
lenguaje muy cortito y ante las personas
desconocida agustín se escondía
es a esta neurólogo le dijo tu hijo
tiene tea
y yo la miré y le pregunté eso que es
tiene cura ella me respondió
el autismo
no era una enfermedad que era una
condición
y que afectaban la interacción social la
conducta
y el desarrollo temprano
ustedes se podrán imaginar ese momento
yo sentí literalmente que tenía una
bomba en mis manos y no sabía dónde
dejarla a quien dárselas
al salir de ese consultorio tenía mis
padres que nos habían acompañado y yo no
tenía el valor para decirle a mis padres
que su primer y que su primer nieto
tenía autismo como les explicaba a ellos
que teníamos que gestionar un
certificado de discapacidad que teníamos
que hacer muchas terapias semanales y
que el autismo no seguiría nunca más de
nuestras vidas
yo no tuve el valor de decírselo en ese
momento entonces es tan solo le dije que
estaba todo bien y agustín ya iba a ser
el clic y va a seguir todavía
agustín estaba en segundo grado y sus
cuadernos volvían vacíos su maestra en
ese momento me decía él viene a pasar la
tarde
que hice yo con el autismo aprendí a
aceptarlo aprendí a ver a través de los
ojos de agustín donde los ruidos fuertes
hacen que él se tape los o los oídos
donde los olores fuertes hacen que le
den náuseas
donde puede ver una película de
superhéroes y te la puede contar de
memoria sin omitir ningún detalle pero
no se puede atar los cordones solos
donde si se moja un poquito la ropa se
cambia porque no tolera estar mojado
donde ir a la peluquería es todo un
desafío porque nadie le quería cortar el
pelo porque a él le dolía el cuero
cabelludo el ruido de la maquinita le
hacía mal
los padres y las familias que tenemos
hijos con discapacidad no estamos
preparados para esto
nadie nos prepara no viene un manual y
nos explica como aceptarlo tan solo nos
toca y nosotros empezamos a echarnos
culpas y empezamos a preguntarnos qué
hice mal pensamos y repasamos todas
nuestras acciones porque creemos que
algo hicimos mal para merecer esto
porque muchas veces creemos que es un
castigo de alguien tener un hijo con
discapacidad
el autismo es una discapacidad invisible
no se ve pero está
recuerdo muchas veces donde el autismo
se hacía presente en nuestras vidas se
hacía visible en la cola de un
supermercado
agustín no toleraba la espera y la gente
nos miraba y no podía creer que un nene
tan grande no puede esperar es que
agustín los segundos son eternos para él
y no tolera la espera
y así les puedo contar en la entrada a
un cine donde agustín entra con las
manos tapándose los oídos hasta que sus
oídos se ambienten al ruido
hoy forma parte de tigre a soltera que
es una asociación que agrupa padres
familiares y amigos de personas con
autismo lo creamos con mi compañera
luciana para que para ayudarnos
mutuamente con distintos padres para
darnos fortaleza acompañarnos porque no
somos pocos somos muchos y ya no estamos
solos
seguramente que todos los que estamos
acá tenemos algún familiar o algún
conocido con autismo a las personas con
discapacidad y que incluirlas hay que
hacer las partes de nosotros porque no
son niños eternos no son angelitos
enviados por dios son personas como vos
como yo
agustín logró vencer muchísimas barreras
hoy lee
a la escuela común
el cadete de los bomberos voluntarios de
general pacheco
y hoy no aspiro a que él sea ningún
profesional solo espero que él sea lo
que él quiere hacer
hoy solo esperan que él viva en una
sociedad donde todos somos partes una
sociedad donde incluir sea más que un
verbo sobre todo espero que él sea feliz
y que nosotros como sociedad podemos
dejarle a las personas con discapacidad
a nuestros hijos
una sociedad más inclusiva una sociedad
donde no nos cueste buscar colegio
porque los colegios nos terminan
eligiendo a nosotros y no nosotros al
colegio
me voy a presentar a agustina el
protagonista de nuestra historia
en eso
gracias
[Música]